stop worrying about the warranty on your
GM or Chrysler automobile President
Obama has announced that your warranty
will be backed by the US government
introducing the Department of Motor
Vehicles automotive repair center how
does it work
just take a number and fill out a simple
form enjoy a refreshment and once your
number is called your DMV automotive
repair expert will inform you that
you've filled out the wrong form but not
to worry your DMV automotive repair
expert will gladly point you to the
correct form just as soon as he gets
back from his break once he returns you
simply repeat the process take a number
fill out the correct form enjoy a
refreshment wait for your number make an
appointment and return in six to eight
weeks to have your car serviced it
really is that easy our management team
of automotive experts can't wait to take
you for a ride so stop worrying and make
an appointment today
hours are 10 a.m. to 3 p.m. Monday
through Thursday excluding holidays
[Music]